[Music]
I see you guys got Walters message -
yeah he's taking the show ending pretty
hard have you seen him no but he did
send me this Heather
Ayanna Jim if you're watching this top 5
has been cancelled this is meant to be
our final episode it's covering a show
that I've wanted to do a countdown since
the very beginning
so as this boy meets cancellation these
are the top 5 best Boy Meets World
episodes number 5
brotherbrother from season 3 the school
year at John Adams high is wrapping up
and Eric Matthews is planning on leaving
home for college with Shawn and Topanga
going away for the summer Cory is
feeling more alone than ever on top of
his best friend and girlfriend leaving
Cory feels like he never truly got to
know his older brother and bad feelings
are brought to the forefront I had to
put this episode on the list because of
how authentic the older brother younger
brother relationship is this season 3
finale has a few more serious scenes
than usual and they're written and acted
out very well it's not hard to be
sympathetic with Cory and Eric's
positions here oh come on Eric the way
you treat me and you gotta ask you
ignore me we do stuff together not only
when you're stuck the older brother Don
the older brother brothers not getting
along as something anybody with a
sibling can easily identify with but the
added twist of Eric supposedly leaving
home for good taxon a feeling of
finality - Eric and Cory's relationship
I don't even know and now I probably
never will 15 years in the same room
Eric obviously this wasn't even close to
the end for their brothers seeing each
other on a regular basis but how its
portrayed leads us to think it might be
the ending twist of this episode was
also a heartbreaker for Eric which
resulted in a more unique arc for him in
following seasons
I've always liked you as a brother you
know but I'm just starting to like you
as a friend I didn't get in in addition
to the heavier moments this episode
doesn't fail to deliver on its signature
comedy detention mr. Matthews detention
mr. Matthews
this diploma which signifies my
intelligence belongs as much to you as
it does to I me I included you brother
brother is a very well executed episode
the subject matter writing and acting
make it stand out number four will have
a good time then from season six Shawn
and Jack's father Chet is back in town
and visiting them at Pennbrook he tells
his sons that he's staying for good this
time as the absentee father seems to be
turning over a new leaf
Jack is excited about the news but Shawn
knows better Chet has been in and out of
his life for years and he's just waiting
for Chet to admit he's leaving again
this family reunion is cut short when
Chet has a heart attack and ends up in
the hospital while there the hunters are
forced to deal with their complicated
family history Chet's arc and Boy Meets
World was one of the more interesting
long-term stories his relationship with
Shawn was strained from the beginning
and resulted in some of Shawn's isolated
loner mentality Shawn has great friends
who constantly watch out for him but
there was always a need to fill a void
for the character and will have a good
time then Shawn and Chet's relationship
hits its climax
I couldn't just stick around good enough
for you
no Shaw's gonna have for you the
introduction of Shawn's half-brother
Jack in season 5 complicated things even
more Jack quickly became one of my
favorite characters he's the opposite of
Shawn in a lot of ways but still has
that same void he's looking to fill
he thinks finally getting to know his
father will do that but when Chet falls
ill everything's put in jeopardy when
Shawn and Jack clash about their
different upbringings it's some of the
most powerful stuff in the show when he
was gone did you walk around and make
believe that everything
okay when inside it was tearing you
apart did you know all right I didn't
get to do any of those things this is
one of if not the saddest episode of Boy
Meets World the emotion is very raw and
the acting by writer strong Matthew
Lawrence and Blake Clark are showcased
in an intimate and affecting way number
three
cult fiction from season four Sean is
roped into a community called the center
after being led there by a classmate who
thinks he might need to hear what their
leader mr. Mack has to offer
Sean quickly realizes that the center is
actually a cult but is attracted to
their message and the charisma of their
leader once they realize what's been
going on the Matthews and mr. Feeny try
to pry Sean away from the organization
however when Sean's former guardian mr.
Turner is involved in a life-threatening
motorcycle accident it's up to Sean to
either lean on his new community or his
lifelong friends
I know another episode that involves
Sean and a hospital but this episode is
very different from we'll have a good
time then this might be Sean and his
most vulnerable and lost he's
manipulated into following mr. Mack and
the aggressive response from the
Matthews has him caught in the middle of
what's best for him the whole cast puts
in great performances I think an unsung
hero of this show is William Russ's
portrayal of Alan Matthews he and Betsy
Randall's Amy are some of TV's best
all-time parents they get angry make
mistakes and can be flawed but they will
always protect their own no no I
understand you see a judgment I made a
long time ago is that Shawn hunter is
the best friend that my kid ever had
brighter strong has baby's best scene in
the whole series in the hospital room
with the unconscious mr. Turner
don't pull me off John don't blow me off
god
I've never asked you for anything and I
never wanted to come to you like this
but don't take Turner away from me I
encourage you to at least go back and
watch that entire scene it's wonderfully
done while Anthony Tyler Quinn's mr.
Turner didn't return following this he
did eventually make a comeback in Girl
Meets World
I think cult fiction is one of the most
memorable episodes they put out most Boy
Meets World fans recognize it right away
as the one where Shawn joins a cult it
was an interesting angle to take on
Shawn's story and let's be honest mr.
Mack is just straight-up creepy are you
centered number 2 7 the hard way from
season 7 Cory Shawn Topanga Eric Angela
Jack and Rachel are going through a big
group fight after pranks they played on
each other went too far Eric is the only
level-headed one with mr. Feeny trying
to make the group reconcile after Rachel
walks out were flashed forward to 7
years in the future at mr. Feeny's
retirement party not having seen each
other in all that time the friends
discover how their lives progressed
without one another 7 the hard way is
absolutely hysterical and we all know
why mr. Matthews mr. squirrels Eric
plays with this is Wilfred Dell at his
best he got to go way over the top with
his humor in this and the results were
amazing
Oh
[Applause]
plays with squirrels is so iconic they
even brought him back in Girl Meets
World and this episode isn't just funny
it has the heart that the show is known
for fully intact it's got a nice message
lose one friend lose all friends lose
yourself well the bulk of this episode
was the fantasy future sequence it's all
tied in well at the end this might be
the most rewatchable episode of the
series and it never fails to make me
laugh
[Music]
oh that's not it this is Boy Meets World
we're talking about just six honorable
mentions
I don't think so since this is the final
top five I wanted to do something
special
across this series I gave about a dozen
episodes perfect scores so before we get
to number one here they are ranked in
order from 12 to 6 happy hundredth
birthday mr. Feeny there's nothing like
being inside Lauren's jacket what then
you could get out of this house and get
a job I'll turn you in
come on man I'm your brother she thought
you were hitting on her what if I was
one more thing I decided to exclude the
series finale brave new world from the
list it's definitely a 10 out of 10
two-parter but really unquantifiable
it's half a clip show combined with the
most emotional goodbyes in television
history and that last scene is near
perfection so just know I love that
episode as much as any other here but I
wanted to highlight the installments
that define this series a little more
over its 7 season run now on to number
one and the number one best Boy Meets
World episode it and then there were
Shawn from season 5 when Shawn Cory
Topanga Angela and their classmate Kenny
are given detention strange occurrences
start presenting themselves slowly a
creepy figure clad in black starts
killing them off as they roll around the
school trying to escape we find out the
killer is someone very familiar with the
group
this is a classic boy meets world
episode and even a favorite of some of
the cast its quotable it's fun it's
interesting and a big change from the
norm of the show the reference is to
scream and even South Park were clever
and appreciate it all the performances
were exceptional it seemed like everyone
was on their a-game here and how could
we forget this cameo right Eric Matthews
and you are the whole story being a
backdrop for how Shawn feels about Cory
and topanga's breakup was a worthy
payoff this was Boy Meets World at its
creative best it is definitely worth a
rewatch that's it where is he
[Music]
and are you're gonna miss us Jim thanks
for all of your help take care of
yourself and thank you guys at a pretty
great run shall we see what the future
holds
[Music]
wait a minute Jim we've never heard you
say it oh yeah we have worked here for
three years and we've never actually
heard you say it in person go on say it
Jim tell it to us no no okay for you see
you around you
fuck yes sparkle Sparkle Sparkle
[Music]
hey everybody I just wanted to come on
one more time and thank you so much for
watching top five over these past two
and a half years it's been a great ride
and Heather and Ayane want to pass along
their gratitude as well for sticking
with us for so long we've had a lot of
fun so thank you for watching and yes
this is the end of the road for top 5 we
will not be uploading episodes on a
consistent weekly basis anymore maybe if
we have an idea down the road we'll
throw up a countdown but it will never
be the way that it's been these past
couple years but I'm not going anywhere
my new show fan scription just launched
a couple months ago a new episode just
went up last week called what if Adonis
Creed was in Rocky 5 a lot of passion
goes into that series so I hope you guys
stick with me on that series also the
fan scription podcast that Rob Walker
and I host we go sort of go deeper into
the changes that we made to these movies
and stuff so if you want to listen to
that or watch it it will be uploaded on
here once a month also my personal
channel youtube.com slash awesome Walter
now the top 5 is over I'll have a chance
to upload on a more consistent basis and
spend some more time on the quality of
those videos so follow along there if
you're a fan of any of my stuff also
Twitter and Facebook if you ever want to
reach out I'm always on there so if you
want to drop a line I usually respond to
people on there so go ahead and reach
out there Heather Heather Roose is going
to be on twitch still she usually
streams on Wednesday nights but she'll
be on Tuesday nights these next couple
weeks so make sure you check her out on
there also on all her social media
accounts Twitter Instagram all that
stuff Ayanna is also still on Facebook
and Twitter and Instagram all that stuff
you could reach her on there this is not
the end of the road for them on channel
awesome either we have some new shows a
lot of new stuff coming up that we're
working on right now so they will be
back very soon and we're all gonna be at
c2e2 this year that's the Chicago comic
and Entertainment Expo March 22nd
through the 24th doug has a booth there
with Brad Jones so we're all gonna be
there so if you see us don't hesitate to
stop by and say hi once again thank you
guys so much for watching top 5 thank
you for sticking with us for so long you
know through awesome comics and
everything it's been great to interact
with you guys so thank you once again
I'll see you right back here on the
channel very soon with fan scription or
anywhere else that I pop
so thank you again for sticking with us
and we'll see you another time
[Music]
[Applause]
you